you
depending on activity level the heart
beats about 60 to 100 times per minute
it may be higher during exercise or
lower at rest a normal heart rate and
rhythm ensures the delivery of
oxygen-rich blood to all of the body's
organs such as the brain and lungs
a group of cells in the heart called the
cardiac conduction system uses
electrical impulses to control the speed
and rhythm of each heartbeat
each heartbeat starts in the right
atrium in the sinoatrial or SA node then
spreads through the walls of the heart
chambers called the atria and ventricles
causing them to contract this process
repeats with each heartbeat
problems with the cardiac conduction
system cause the heart to have an
abnormal rhythm called an arrhythmia
this may cause an irregular pulse
arrhythmias may happen in the atria or
ventricles
types of arrhythmias include
fibrillation which is an irregular
heartbeat
rhythm
tachycardia which is a fast heartbeat of
more than 100 beats per minute
and bradycardia which is a slow
heartbeat of less than sixty beats per
minute
atrial fibrillation is the most common
type of arrhythmia random impulses cause
the atria to fibrillate or twitch
rapidly and randomly
tachycardia in the atria is called
supraventricular tachycardia
focal atrial tachycardia small areas
within the atrial wall start or pass
along impulses that cause the atria to
contract rapidly but with a regular
rhythm
in atrial flutter larger areas within
the atrial wall start or pass along
impulses that cause the atria to
contract rapidly but with a regular
rhythm
tachycardia may also happen in the
ventricles with rapid and regular
contractions
the body may not receive enough blood
because the ventricles contract before
completely filling with blood
the most serious arrhythmia is
ventricular fibrillation where many
random impulses fire rapidly within the
ventricular walls in ventricular
fibrillation the ventricles are
quivering instead of beating this is a
medical emergency because the heart
cannot effectively pump blood to the
body or itself
sometimes problems with the SA node or
problems with the pathway of the
electrical impulses to the ventricles
can cause the slow heartbeat in
bradycardia if the heart beats too
slowly the body may not receive enough
oxygen rich blood
depending on the type of arrhythmia a
doctor may recommend one or more of the
following treatments
lifestyle changes such as eating a
heart-healthy diet
exercising
and quitting smoking
medication such as anti-arrhythmic drugs
and beta blockers
catheter ablation where thin wires
inserted into the heart destroy the
tissue causing the arrhythmia with hot
or cold energy
and implantable devices such as a
pacemaker or defibrillator to correct
the pace or rhythm of the heart